so food is like been your passion
cooking and stuff right so why because I
feel like you guys because there's like
a new like hot chicken's always been a
thing but there's like this new yeah
like everywhere you go now there's a hot
chicken spot oh yeah especially in the
valley yeah yeah I feel like every other
corner there's a new like you gotta have
fake Dave's popping up right right
wherever you [ __ ] go like I was just
Dave's not chicken um I was at the
Glendale mall in the new spot and
there's a hot chicken place I was like
look at this it's [ __ ] just popping
up everywhere you had it too
um but um you guys are very responsible
for like a trend in like restaurants
yeah
um why hot chicken
um I mean it's a pretty crazy story yeah
so
um so hot chicken uh started kind of
like we've always been a big fan of
fried chicken right right so hot chicken
kind of started getting trending in La
you know one of the chefs had a
Nashville brought it down to LA and uh
me and Dave tried and immediately I mean
we fell in love with it right we're like
dude this is so good and uh we're like
well dude you know you're like you're a
chef you know I I have like a little bit
of background in marketing I'm pretty
good you know social media whatever I'm
like what if we got together and we made
a recipe and and you know what if we
tried to like get in on this trend but
uh the funny thing is like at the time
we're obviously dead broke you know Dave
is working at a restaurant that doesn't
pay anything right I'm doing acting
which doesn't pay anything right uh and
then we had a a third friend named Tommy
who I met in kindergarten so three of us
like that were like all right why don't
we just work on a recipe for now right
like okay we don't have money for
something let's just work on a recipe so
we go to Dave's house every day and our
day was just like you know we finish up
work go to Dave's house uh you know
start cooking up food in this kitchen
you know buy just the ingredients and
cook it and uh we might have done this
for like
five months where we just worked on a
recipe wow yeah and then one thing the
recipe was kind of done right and
there's only so much you can do and so
we're like sitting there at Dave's house
like all right well we have the food but
like what do we do like we have no money
you know like how do we how do we get
this out there like how do we sell this
to people right so uh our friend Tommy's
like uh well uh what if we try like a
pop-up you know we could do some some
floor like pop-ups pop up somewhere
another one of our friends I was like
yes like I know a lot of people that do
that it's like they'll pop up in places
they'll wrap their stuff up at night and
then they'll just leave so we're like
all right well we could we could
probably get together a pop-up right so
we started scrapping together a little
bit of money dude and uh we literally
Noble subscribed together 900 that's all
we can get they took his last check 300
bucks I had like a few hundred bucks
saved up Tommy's like I'll put in the
rest whatever we need so we went to uh
Target you know we bought like a little
canopy and we went on Craigslist and
whenever we want a little fryer we took
some tables from our parents houses and
some chairs and uh we just popped up one
day yeah yeah Tommy uh linked up with
this guy that he used to work with and
he offered to give us like one little
spot in a parking lot it was literally
one spot in a public parking lot wow so
we set up our shop over there
posted on social media that we're open
and our first night went like 40 bucks
obviously it's just a bunch of kids in a
parking lot uh and then uh you know we
just you know started like pushing on
social media you know we knew we had a
good product we started you know we'd
run around the block screaming we got
chicken we got chicken we were literally
screaming hey we got chicken come buy
some chicken you know what I mean uh and
then we got noticed we got noticed we
got written up in an article uh we got
written up in either LA and uh this guy
wrote an insane article about as far of
the alien what year is this this is
2017. what the [ __ ] yes yeah yeah and
then do we get to the yeah we get to the
pop-up the next day after I lived here
in 2017. yeah it was on Hollywood
Boulevard dude it was right on uh
Hollywood and Normandy yeah do you know
where Jumbo's Clown Room is yeah yeah it
was literally across the street we'd go
to the line we'd go to the jumbos line
and hand out samples to people okay
you'll come get some chicken yeah and
then like see there was like 90 people
in our pop-ups like waiting for us when
we got there what and that was early
that was like the first week we were
there yeah it was like five days yeah
okay so you guys get a buzz yeah
obviously you're kind of like the Talk
of the Town yeah when where's your first
brick and mortar mortar location where's
that at that's on Western yeah close by
it was like a mile away yeah so I think
pretty early on we realized seven months
into it yeah and then we realized like
yo this is pretty big you know like if
we're pretty responsible with this like
we could really blow it up and we could
be really professional so we started
getting really disciplined and every
dollar we make we'd invest back into the
pop-up until we couldn't anymore and
then every other dollar after that kind
of just went to saving up to like get a
brick and mortar